hey guys it's Tuesday I'm Dan I'm Joe
gonna start for Dennis what news
last up you probably remember a couple
of stories we've been talking about over
the last few weeks about how not many of
you are playing low breakers and little
break is create a cliff Lozinski would
like more of you to play low breakers
beginning September 28 through to
October 2nd you'll be able to play
lawbreakers for free on Steam on top of
that if you like the game after playing
it for no money you'll be able to pick
it up for 25% off if you're not a
hundred percent sure what low break is
is a brand new trailer has arrived to
explain it to you it's mostly shooting
things it is most of shooting things but
what do you think Danny gonna give a
shot yeah great I mean why not why not
why not give it a shot it is pretty cool
I've played a little bit of it you can
shoot behind you to make yourself go
forward which is just like cool and real
nineties action movie there's you know I
like the goofiness of the idea of the
team's being called the law and the
breakers I think that's super goofy and
just like kind of dumb and cool but yeah
I mean give it a shot I hope you guys
can get a game though because like we've
said in our last few stories we've had a
really hard time getting a game so maybe
with this free weekend at least it'll
get the play account back up which will
hopefully reignites an interest in it
the video game voice actors strike the
longest-running strike and sag after
history has come to a tentative end
after eleven months an agreement appears
to have been reached between the Union
and eleven game companies including
Activision Electronic Arts and Warner
Brothers the terms of the agreements
include any bonus structure that
provides an additional payment to
performers and an additional full-scale
payment for every 500,000 copies of game
ships up to two million copies the
strike began last October and was
according to the Union due to the video
game industry refusing to offer residual
payment bonuses and other profit sharing
opportunities among other issues such as
their refusal to limit vocally stressful
performance sessions to two hours to
help prevent actors from damaging their
voice chief negotiator for the video
game companies Scott whittlin said they
worked hard to reach the deal and
explained the new contract provides a
substantial pay increase for performers
through both increases in session fees
and additional compensation tied to a
performance contribution to the video
game in addition the video game
companies agreed to additional
transparency and bookings and to
continue to cooperate with sag-aftra
in the area of safety including vocal
stress the new contract will be in place
for three years once it's reviewed and
confirmed by sag AFTRA your knocked-over
will be sure to keep you updated on
once I keep on coming back finally ahead
of the release of Star Wars Battlefront
2 in just over a month yeah you have
released a brand new trailer that shows
off all the modes maps and other cool
stuff you'll be able to get into this
one could be considered marlax spoilery
so just a heads up in terms of modes
you'll be able to engage in full-scale
galactic combat in 40 player galactic
assault with maps that will take you all
over a galaxy far away including star
killer base and Kamino
there's also the 24 player Starfighter
assault which will let you dogfight in
large-scale space battles as well as the
objective based mode strike close
quarters combat blast and heroes and
villains there's also an arcade mode
that lets you play offline in solo or
split-screen co-op the trailer also
details the new star card and
progression systems Star Wars
Battlefront 2 is out on November 17th
for ps4 Xbox one and PC and the open
beta kicks off next week from October
6th to 9th if you preorder before
October 1st you'll get access from
October 4th that's everything we have
for you today
yeah not imply here should I catch you
my memory